Skarsgard began developing his take on
Pennywise well before he actually
started shooting any scenes there was
like all these different things that
I've been meaning to put into a
character then this character appeared
and I kind of I just kind of put all
these things together pennywise's
demonic grin for example is created by
Skarsgard drooping his lower lip down so
that it almost comes to a point that's
not a prosthetic or digital effect but
simply something he's always been able
to do to my uh just for that camera
number three yeah there we go
director Andy musketti had the idea that
sometimes one of pennywise's eyes would
wander and told Skarsgard that he would
add the lazy eye in digitally in
post-production Skarsgard explained that
he could do it and revealed that he
could trigger his own lazy eye yeah kind
of a lazy eye and I can like
make it go one of the chances that the
actor that you cast can do that
practically